[Música]
m dia mudança é de modificação e me dá
talvez palavra que paute a nossa
contemporaneidade e medir mobilidade
como mobilidade um conceito muito amplo
não quero restringir um pouco essa
habilidade para falar exclusivamente da
mobilidade social
mais que isso a ideia é falar da
mobilidade social por meio da educação
que talvez seja uma característica das
últimas duas décadas sobretudo no brasil
e não poderia deixar passar
desapercebido
a idéia de bauman que fala que os tempos
são líquidos que as coisas são feitas
para não durar
as coisas são feitas para que se
modifiquem e algumas modificações no
brasil nos últimos anos têm sido
benéficas
eu entendo basicamente que a mobilidade
ela acontece em alguns momentos e
causada por algumas questões
hoje eu quero provocar vocês um pouco
trazendo a idéia de charles darwin que
bangu
a princípio você pode pensar o que teria
ver charles darwin com um banco um
bairro do rio de janeiro bastante
conhecido por uma questão bastante
peculiar mas que a idéia hoje talvez
mudar um pouco a sua percepção a
mobilidade acontece em cinco atos
o primeiro ato é a transposição de
alguns obstáculos que o maior obstáculo
é fazer o aluno que não teve acesso a
uma educação de qualidade conseguir
competir em nível de igualdade
algumas características importantes 44%
dos brasileiros não leem grande parte
dele
grande parte deles não consegue entender
o que lê e pior que isso 8% somente 8%
seguem se expressar de alguma maneira
agora vocês imaginem esse tipo de
expressão em um exame nacional como enem
para quem não sabe o enem é o segundo
maior exame de vestibular no mundo e no
enem caia tom complicada redação pontos
aqui conseguiram escrever a redação em
uma hora
é o que pede um ex que solicita o mec em
relação ao tempo de prova e algumas
curiosidades
o mec também pede do aluno uso de
repertório sociocultural produtivo é um
critério de correção inclusive isso é
até muito engraçado porque aparece como
é que exige um aluno mas como é que pede
um aluno que não existe no brasil re
primeiro ele precisa ter repertório já
complicado ele não lê
segundo tem que ser sócio cultural e
depois tem que ser produtivo que é
produtivo povo que não lê
como já dizia kant quem não sabe o que
procura não identifica o que acha e
então se alguma não sabe nem que ele
está procurando como é que ele vai
conseguir se alimentar de conteúdo
esses números sem dúvida eles se
refletem porque acontece na prova o ano
passado 2016 foi o ano com recorde de
notas baixas
como assim simples dos mais de 5 milhões
de alunos que produziram redação somente
77 conseguiu nota máxima ou seja dos
mais de 5 milhões de alunos se
inscreveram na redação do enem no ano
passado somente 77 conseguiram a nota
máxima
uma façanha realmente uma façanha é a
uma casa de notas mil pelo brasil e tudo
mais
eu tive a felicidade de ter cinco alunos
com essa nota máxima cinco alunos
conseguindo a nota máxima em um ano
muito complicado
e olha que curioso os temas não pareceu
tão difíceis
o enem teve duas aplicações primeiro
tema foi caminhos para combater a
intolerância religiosa no brasil
e o segundo foi caminhos para combater o
racismo no brasil
um dos temas que na minha visão seria um
relativamente tranqüilos e escrever mas
que os números mostraram o contrário e
são gráficos e dados do mec
e uma coisa curiosa é esse é o
percentual de pessoas que tinham ganho
no ano passado e qual é a surpresa
primeiro 50 mil já é bastante coisa e um
ano bem complicado como aquele e mais
que isso
destas cinco notas mil duas foram de
longe meus de bangu e alguém está
pensando caramba ilegal que façanha
talvez seja uma visão um pouco
estereotipada do que o bangu e é preciso
também de justificar algumas coisas pra
vocês terem noção se o tema do enem é
caminho para combater a intolerância
religiosa e saul precisava ter noção de
que o estado é laico ele precisava ter
noção de que é crime ele pesava apenas o
racismo é um crime inafiançável e
imprescritível por exemplo mas como já
disse mais cedo esse aluno não lê não
sabe que a equipe não sabe quem 3 que
tivemos eu e não sabe que a constituição
e aí algumas pessoas perguntaram com
este método inovador que você usou muito
simples
rubem alves ele tem uma frase
interessante que ele fala que o
conhecimento ele se dá de três formas
uma e pela curiosidade mas como disse
mais cedo esse ano não tem curiosidade
por nada
o segundo é pelo trauma eu não gostaria
que esse aluno ficar reprovado não
conseguisse aprovação para poder
aprender com o erro ea terceira é o
método que a massificação
esse aluno e fica mais ou menos 15 anos
na escola
ele chega sem saber fazer redação no
curso preparatório
quantas gerações você acha que esse
aluno precisa fazer para conseguir
alcançar uma nota 900 por exemplo nem
quantas gerações em um ano você acha que
esse aluno precisa fazer então essa
estratégia primeiro aquela massificação
lavagem cerebral que depois começarem
curtir conteúdo processo de remoção foi
preciso eu vou conversar com meus amigos
de história conversar com meus amigos
geografia de sociologia e de filosofia
para poderem explicar como pássaros em
sala porque sozinho ninguém faz nada
o diferencial interessante o enem tem
como base a idéia dos direitos humanos e
eu marquei uma aula eu e um professor de
direito discutir alguns temas e
constituição e o tema caiu racismo
intolerância ou seja essa aula de
constituição explicando
usar a lei como usar a base legal dentro
de uma redação com certeza também fez
bastante diferença
e aí tudo isso é fácil você talvez se
perguntar quem sou eu e o segundo ato é
para que haja mobilidade é preciso que
haja pessoas
é preciso que haja agentes de
transformação social
meu nome é vitor miranda eu sou
professor de língua portuguesa e de
redação e na minha formação é bem
peculiar
eu sempre convivi em dois mundos muito
distintos porque meu pai ele é professor
de história da rede privada de ensino e
hoje mesmo aposentado continua da aula
a minha mãe ela é professora da rede
pública do rio de janeiro aposentada e
hoje dedica à vida acadêmica
então com certeza é isso influenciou a
formação e muito curioso porque de um
lado eu convivi com meu pai em escolas
particulares com alunos com melhor poder
aquisitivo e à cantina era festa
o refeitório era maravilhoso do outro
lado convive com a minha mãe escola
pública chegava de manhã e passava o dia
com ela é mãe que trabalha precisa ficar
com o filho também não tinha enfrentado
sozinho e meu irmão mas não ficarmos com
ela na escola e algumas coisas foram me
marcando e sempre repensando algumas
coisas e pensando até quando eu cheguei
até aqui uma história que me marcou
bastante e tinha talvez 89 anos e até
pediam para contar essa história eu nem
falo muito com meus alunos mas vamos lá
é certo dia eu tô no intervalo tal da
china também um refeitório e tudo mais
é eu vejo todo mundo levantando no canto
o menino mais novo que é o de vencer o
ceará até lá jardim e todo mundo saindo
ele escondido um canto a comida do dia
era macarrão com salsicha é uma comida é
bastante freqüente em escolas públicas
comida bem feita inclusive eu vejo
aquele garoto no canto da sala no canto
refeitório todo mundo levantou dele
enquanto meio sem saber para onde ia
fazer eu vejo que está criando o prato o
corpo dele
e aí mesma hora a minha mãe fala mamãe
eu tenho que no prato e tal
a minha mãe me manda entrar para a sala
vai lá ver tal quando ela chega à casa
ela conversa comigo explica que muitos
jovens mas é jovem
muitas crianças vão para a escola
somente pela refeição
muitos brasileiros na escola pública vão
para a escola porque não tem condição de
se alimentar em casa e aquele menino
segundo ela estava guardando comida para
levar programa jogo
como é que isso vai impactar de uma
maneira muito novo nessa época é mais
uma história que me marcou e quantas
vezes eu não tive que ficar escondido na
escola por causa do tiroteio quantas
vezes eu não precisei esperar escola
fechar porque o traficante fala pra
fazer isso isso isso em comunidades
carentes em escolas públicas quem manda
é o estado a poder paralelo existe outro
estado o estado paralelo que comanda
tudo na sociedade brasileira
não preciso dizer pra vocês que a
educação pública no brasil não funciona
ou não é preciso dizer basicamente com
certeza tudo isso foi informando que uma
pessoa para chegar até aqui como
professor e hoje é engraçado porque eu
continuo convivendo os dois mundos
porque o dólar em bangu que é um local
desenvolvido mas é na zona oeste do rio
é reconhecido como um local que não é
digamos de pessoas com mais força
financeira e também dólar em locais da
pessoa de classe média alta
então continuo convivendo nesses dois
mundos meus pais estão me ouvindo agora
estamos vendo neste momento e talvez
nunca tenha falado muito para isso mas
tem bastante orgulho e eles são parte do
que eu sou hoje se eu não sou melhor que
eu posso ser com certeza não foi por
culpa deles e sim por mérito meu
então basicamente sem dúvida nenhuma a
minha formação tem muito a ver com a
forma como os pais lidam com essa
questão
e aí o inesperado acontece e eu como
professor eu como professor consiga a
façanha de ver dois a um e mail de bangu
alcançando a nota máxima aaa nota mil na
redação
saiu o geoms a em vários sites do brasil
todo deram entrevistas ficaram muito
felizes
e deixe cinco alunos de anil dois são de
bambu e destes dois alunos na verdade um
são dois são duas
outra característica dos tempos atuais a
mobilidade social de mulheres que
outrora não trabalhavam e hoje são
maioria no ingresso ao ensino superior
por exemplo
então essa também é uma característica
bastante interessante destes tempos
atuais
3º a surpresa nós temos são muitas
pessoas se surpreendem com isso tem um
treinamento em são paulo
é meio do ano no meio deste ano
conversando com alguns colegas que eu é
a trabalhou em banco e muitos deles
começaram a perguntar coisas do tipo
o vovô porque você trabalha o bangu se
submete a isso eu pensei não vou te dar
lá acho que você pode gostar de você tá
louco
o que está acontecendo com você você tem
capacidade para dar lugares mais
tranqüilos foi calma já tranquilo os
alunos são maravilhosos e são carinhosos
muito carinhoso como é que você faz para
entrar lá comecei a pensar como assim
entrar lá entende
sinceramente não entendi frio que vocês
estão falando especificamente eu
descobri o seguinte eles achavam que eu
estava dando aula
aqui está uma pessoa que estava dando
aula no presídio para os ver como é que
a visão estereotipada porque bangu
infelizmente sai dos noticiários
brasileiros com relação à ideia dos
presídios bambu não é reconhecido por
questões acadêmicas e essa talvez tenha
sido uma surpresa bastante interessante
para eles eu achei engraçado né
perguntando como é que eu chego lá como
eu consigo e quando foi que os homens
eram carinhosos ricardo em outros como é
que pode isso alunos cariocas dentro
desse ambiente até desde mich ficar a
ideia de que o bambu é um presídio
foi complicado mas convém surpresa sim a
surpresa porque para haver a mobilidade
social é preciso haver surpresa porque a
mobilidade social é uma coisa que está
escrita socialmente é algo que acontece
a partir de alguma causa existe uma
relação de causalidade e pra mim a
mobilidade social problema e permanente
tem a ver com o conceito de
educação o quarto ato o quarto anomalia
porque é uma anomalia é uma anomalia
sistêmica uma onde o banco conseguiu
matar mil aliás é uma anomalia sistema
dois alunos conseguirem nota mil
aliás é uma anomalia sistêmica deixa os
dois álbuns que chama mil
uma delas conseguiu passar para medicina
na ufrj
o curso mais concorrido no sisu
mas eu não acho que isso é impossível
impossível e neste mesmo curso do
trabalho houve mais de 50 notas acima de
isso sim que a anomalia porque darwin
porque bangu simples conceito de
darwinismo social pregava a idéia de que
o homem é fruto da raça do meio e do
contexto histórico ou seja se este aluno
está em um contexto histórico é que
pessoas não conseguem vencer ele também
não vai vencer
queriam provar idéia de que
biologicamente havia alguma diferença e
havia raças superiores inferiores e
regimes fascistas na europa por exemplo
se valeu dessa idéia errônea provada
biologicamente errada mas muitas pessoas
pensavam assim se ele é fruto da raça
então pelo amor de deus que ela não vai
conseguir contexto histórico raça e meio
se o meio de bambu não tem uma educação
de qualidade como é que isso vai
conseguir isso seguir o curso natural
das coisas é mais fácil um aluno meu
escola particular conseguiu nota mil
acho legal muito bom realmente uma
façanha cinco alunos mas realmente a
façanha foram os 2 a 1 longe o melhor
as duas alunas essa basicamente a
façanha resiliência tudo
o professor precisa mostrar o aluno que
é possível o professor precisa mostrar o
que há algo palpável o professor ele é o
agente de transformação sim mas no
brasil até por saber que o professor é o
agente de transformação poucas são as
pessoas que conseguem ter essa área uma
algo importante para vocês terem noção
quanto os professores quanto os
professores não são aqueles que falam
problema assim que isso quero ser
professor tá doido
diferentemente dos meus pais que sempre
me incentivaram e eu sou bastante feliz
sendo professor e o caminho
o ato o quinto ato o ato que realmente
faz a diferença é o caminho
a visão de uma sociedade igualitária é
algo o toque sempre haverá pessoas com a
estrada asfaltada e sempre haverá
pessoas com a estrada um problemas
e sabe quem é que pode asfaltar essa
estada para que todos consigam ter um
caminho pleno o professor
todo professor brasileiro um super herói
pra vocês terem noção semana passada
o brasil é o país com o maior número de
violência contra o professor no mundo
eu não tem problemas com relação ao
mesmo mês em relação a isso mas alguns
colegas que têm problemas graves em
relação à violência e falta de segurança
nas escolas
eu sou fruto dia uma equação irregular
que deu resposta satisfatória o
professor e tenho muito orgulho disso e
todo professor como super-herói aliás
todos super herói ele tem uma arma
apesar de armas e é uma palavra muito
forte e nelson mandela dizia que a
educação é a melhor arma para mudar o
mundo
a arma talvez seja algo até um pouco
violento conotação forte é preciso
pensar um pouco sobre isso aliás eu
prefiro pensar que todo professor tem um
instrumento de mudança
esse é meu instrumento de mudança eu sou
um super herói de mudança é o piloto é a
caneta de quadro
eu sou super herói e eu consigo fazer
micro mudanças micro mudanças são apenas
duas alunas uma passou para medicina
mas é uma aluna de bangu que passou para
medicina e com certeza vai mudar a vida
da família dela toda porque agora a
família dela as pessoas ao redor dela
ter um referencial de sucesso passar um
mês se não é possível não é possível eu
sou super herói essa arma
eu sou professor e a solução a solução é
educação para que os nossos tempos
líquidos sejam conhecidos como a era da
mobilidade a era da mobilidade social
muito obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]